نقلت صحيفه هارت الاسرائيليه عن مسؤول
الاسرائيلي الكبير ان السودان يستعد
للتوقيع على اتفاق التطبيع عند العلاقات
مع اسرائيل
بين تل ابيب والخرطوم بمساعده امريكيه
حققت تقدما ملموسا بين الجانبين يبشر بقرب
توقيع على اتفاقات ابرهم وذكرت تعرضت انما
وصفتها بالعلاقات الجيده بين القياده
السياسيه الامنيه الاسرائيليه مع السلطات
العسكريه في السودان احيت جهود التطبيع من
جديد وكان السودان اعلنت في اكتوبر تشرين
الاول لعام 2020 نيته الانضمام الى
الاتفاقات ابرهم لكنه امتنع عن ذلك بعد
وقوع انقلاب عسكري تسبب بتوقف الاتصالات
العلنيه بين الجانبين
وفي هذه الاثناء هبطت طائره الاسرائيليه
في مطار الخرطوم وكشفت وسائل الاعلام
الاسرائيليه ان الطائرات التي تحمل اسم
اقلعت من مطار تل ابيب فجرا اليوم متوجهه
الى السودان